campioni si nasce non si diventa questa
era la
che circolava
gli anni io sicuro mio fratello maggiore
che correre in moto tanta passione ma
pochissimi risultati e questa sentenza
di mia mamma su di noi era veramente
difficile da digerire al 10 anni perché
era un po come dire beh noi siamo stati
baciati dal signore e ed era veramente
difficile per riuscire a pensare di non
poter stringere nessun nessun successo
quando sei così piccolo e devo dire che
questa fase mi ha condizionato tanto
così tanto che neanche motivato nella
prima parte del della mia infanzia e ma
non del tutto nel senso che non studiavo
perché tanto non avevo nessuna
possibilità di poter arrivare però
salvavo un sacco gli altri visto che gli
altri sarebbero diventati qualcuno io
intanto informavo gli altri studiano e
passavo la maggior parte del mio tempo a
firmare autografi
nessun mio diario quando il piccolo
e intanto mi sono allenato a studiare
gli altri tantissimo e devo dire che
questo dubbio amletico tra il voler
essere se stessi e dover diventare
qualcuno è una cosa che mi ha
condizionato anche ne abbiamo pila di
una parte della carriera perché quando
guardavo gli altri modelli vincenti e
allenatori ricevo beh sono molto diversi
da me quindi un'altra volta non ha
speranze e credo che questa cosa sia
stata la cosa che questo fraintendimento
tra il voler essere se stessi per
diventare qualcuno sia stato uno di quei
fraintendimenti che mi hanno
accompagnato tanto e uni quelle cose
dove forse adesso ho messo di più la mia
attenzione perché il mio desiderio più
grande quando è entrato in palestra e
quello di mettere le mie ragazze nelle
condizioni di esprimere se stesse e mi
piace tantissimo
quel pezzo del film l'attimo fuggente
quando robin williams sale sulla
cattedra no e poi fa salire i ragazzi
sulla cattedra e ridice trovate nuove
strade
ma la cosa bella che fa lui è che lui si
toglie da modello e fa salire
direttamente i ragazzi sulla cattedra
cioè fa diventare dei ragazzi
il modello di se stessi e fa salire
tutti sulla cattedra quindi tutti hanno
talento e tutti devono salire su quella
cattedra cercare il proprio il proprio
modello il proprio modo di essere e
oltre a questo fraintendimento un altro
di quelli che poi ho scoperto essere
forse quello che mi ha condizionato di
più tra i fraintendimenti
nel mio lavoro è stato quello che lo
sport non è una sfida contro qualcuno o
essere meglio di qualcuno è addirittura
volte
vengono usati termini medici per
descriverlo sport e invece ho scoperto
che la cosa bella è fare sport
soprattutto guardando i grandi campioni
è che la sfida con se stessi la sfida
con se stessi alla sfida che alimenta un
atleta quando vedete un grande campione
come può essere valentino come questa e
roger federer che contamino riescono a
smettere ma non lo fanno perché hanno
ancora questa smania di per forza voler
vincere ma di mettersi ancora una volta
alla prova e questo lo fanno i grandi
campioni non amici imprenditori
chiunque ha voglia di sfidare se stesso
e questa sfida con con se stessi e la
cosa che secondo me è la prima cosa che
dobbiamo fare è della prima cosa che ho
chiesto alle ragazze sfidate voi stesse
sfida fidate voi stesse ad essere le
migliori al mondo ed essere migliori al
mondo non è in funzione di qualcuno
quando ho preso la nazionale le ragazze
veniamo da un periodo un po difficile e
mi hanno chiesto vogliamo andare in
campo ed essere competitive contro
chiunque e io ho chiesto loro beh come
pensate di poter correre più veloce che
il più veloce al mondo
pensate a 100 metri come pensate di
poter correre più veloce di rivolta e
l'unico modo per correre più veloce di
lui è corre ogni giorno più veloce di
quello che siete abituate a fare e poi
piano piano il correre più veloce di
bolt sarà una conseguenza ma non un
obiettivo
e devo dire che su questa cosa bisogna
stare molto attenti a cos'è che ci muove
se sono i desideri ei sogni perché una
di quelle cose che ho scoperto nella mia
carriera che molto spesso il sogno sono
pericolosi perché ti gratificano sono al
momento in cui gli realizzi durano un
attimo e soprattutto di motivano in base
a quanto
senti vicini i desideri invece sono
quella cosa che ci motivano già solo per
il fatto che la vita cioè tipo quando io
in palestra e sento di voler mettere le
ragazze nella condizione di essere le
video che al mondo
io sto bene non è detto che ci riesca
quell oggetto del desiderio è un'altra
cosa adesso non ha conseguenze
e in questa sfida con voi stessi vela
giocate su tre su tre aspetti il primo è
sapere dobbiamo conoscere tanto di noi e
di quello che ci circonda e molto spesso
il cosa facciamo
che cosa sappiamo è sottoposto a un
giudizio è la cosa che vi dico state
denti a giudizi perché il giudizio è
solo una foto della realtà non è la
verità
quindi un punto non determina una
tendenza un'azione non rispecchia la
vostra identità quindi il sapere delle
tante informazioni è basilare solo per
un motivo perché da quelle informazioni
dovete saper fare qualcosa di vostro
ossia tradurre tutte quelle informazioni
in un apprendimento in una percezione in
un tizio né che ai box tra che è
assolutamente vostra che fa parte di voi
ma l'ultimo livello in cui si fa la
differenza e di saper essere quindi se
sapere importante saper fare è qualcosa
che fa parte del nostro trento e saper
essere il perché fate le cose il perché
siete unici e siete autentici e la cosa
più importante
ogni tanto sento persone che mi dicono
le tecniche per comunicare solo queste
queste queste un sacco di regole secondo
me l'unica tecnica per comunicare essere
autentici essere se stessi
a me però che se solo la prima sfida la
sfida con voi stessi
perché poi verrà giocate su altri due
campi e la sfida con l'ambiente ossia
quella squadra e nella sfida con la
squadra
la cosa che secondo me è più importante
il nome giusto alle cose quando sono
tornato dal mondiale
tutti mi dicevano ah no questa medaglia
profuma d'oro spesa con melo assomiglia
a loro la mia medaglia d'argento
profumata argento e tutta d'argento e
per come la guardo ed argento ed è
giustissimo valorizzare per quella che è
dare un nome molto spesso noi spacchiamo
dare il nome alle cose perché perché
perdere è normale perdere non è
sbagliato perdere il normale vincere
speciale e se noi cambiamo il valore
queste due cose tutto si complica tutto
diventa molto più difficile è molto
speso poi noi non vogliamo le occasioni
perché il caso non esiste così sono le
occasioni ma spesso le occasioni ha una
forma e soprattutto un sapore che a
volte non è quello che noi ci aspettiamo
e quando a volte ringo etichettato come
uno ottimista io non mi rete con un
ottimista
uno che vede il bicchiere mezzo pieno
perché si trovi e bicchieri non va mica
guardate i van de put i e quindi se
e quindi se ci capita un bicchiere di
quelli difficili di inserire e dobbiamo
tapparci il naso ma buttarlo giù perché
oggi ci sto a capire quello e quando
invece visto che siamo in vendita
beviamo un buonissimo calice dobbiamo
restare sobri ed è lì e nell'equilibrio
che poi troviamo la nostra strada
ultima sfida quella con l'avversario
nella sfida con l'avversario
la cosa che è più importante e libera il
momento nel vivere il presente quando
gli chiedono le mie ragazze cos'è che vi
accompagna nella massima prestazione e
cos'è che pensano quando saremo sempre
stazione ai loro mi rispondono a niente
hanno un vuoto assoluto un po assoluto
e sapete perché perché sono sfidando
loro stesse stanno sfidando loro stesse
e l'avversario è solo il metodo di
misura per vedere dove sono arrivate e
questo è il più grande e antistress e
antidepressivo del mondo per quando tu
vivi in sfida con te stesso e non per
essere superiore a qualcuno vi assicuro
che gli cambia la vita
e in questa sfida con con se stesse
molto spesso siamo noi allenatori che
facciamo un po di confusione perché
molto spesso noi allenatori
cambiamo il valore alle cose perché loro
sono così immersi quello che stanno
facendo che alla fine come se fosse un
giorno normale non è una finale loro
semplificano una finale trasformandolo
in un giorno normale e rendendo peggior
normale poi finiscono per trasformarlo
in speciale
beh in questa operazione di vuoto che le
ragazze fanno
noi allenatori a volte facciamo dei
danni dei dati del tipo ok
oggi dobbiamo fare la partita perfetta
bene allora giocato oggi dobbiamo dare
il 120 per cento centro basta cioè 120 e
solo lì
l'indice che non ci fidiamo della nostra
identità non è sufficiente per vincere
perché crediamo che gli altri abbiano
l'identità la migliore della nostra e
quindi che facciamo
incominciamo dire queste cose come dire
la nostra identità non è sufficiente e
togliamo le ragazze da quel vuoto che
invece loro hanno bisogno per essere in
massima prestazione e volevo chiudere
visto che avevo parlato un po di
fraintendimenti no essere o diventare il
fraintendimento sogni desideri ma sapete
qual è il fraintendimento più grande è
che mia mamma avere ragione campioni si
nasce in una bimba piccola
e quando è nata la mia vita mi sono reso
conto che i campioni si nasce quando lei
aveva un anno e si arrampicava sul
divano non c'era fortemente la mamma
sale sul divano e cade o una carognata
incredibile ma c'era ma ormai tranquillo
addebito su lei felice di piangere ci
riprova ricade e io sei stupida no è una
campionessa
perché è ossessiva e curiosa come un
campione sono solo due e vi saluto con
questo le cose che ci tolgono il fatto
di essere campioni i giudizi e le paure
i gdt lepore si tolgono questa
possibilità di essere campi
di essere ogni giorno allenati ad essere
i migliori al mondo
buon andamento
[Applauso]